ein mord mit folgen die
bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt ob
russland den auftrag gab einen mann im
berliner tiergarten umzubringen
deutschland weiß zwei russische
diplomaten aus aufatmen beim
geburtstagsgipfel die nato-mitglieder
erneuern ihren beistandspakt aber die
probleme des bündnisses bleibt und ein
platz auf der negativliste deutschland
ist eines der drei länder weltweit mit
den größten klimaschäden warnt eine
langzeitstudie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers unten abend hinein
danke dass sie bei uns sind kristin hat
den sport nachher genannt und wir sind
beim nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
mittwoch der beginnt mit einem mordfall
der mittlerweile in der politik weite
kreise zieht und zu einer diplomatischen
krise für zwischen deutschland und
russland
die bundesregierung hat zwei russische
diplomaten aus deutschland ausgewiesen
weil die deutschen ermittler
anhaltspunkte dafür haben dass russland
hinter einem mutmaßlichen auftragsmord
in berlin steckt und darum geht es
berlin tiergarten dreiundzwanzigster
august am hellichten tag wird ein 40
jahre alter mann aus georgien erschossen
in der nähe des tatorts nimmt die
polizei einen verdächtigen fest einen
russischen staatsbürger
jetzt ermittelt die bundesanwaltschaft
in diesem fall weil sie anhaltspunkte
hat dass der mann getötet wurde im
auftrag russischer stellen
das ganze erinnert an den fall skripal
vergangenes jahr in südengland dort
hatten nach erkenntnissen der briten
zwei russische agentin einen überläufer
und seine tochter vergiftet die reaktion
heute aus moskau das seien alles
haltlose spekulationen und es werde
vergeltungsmaßnahmen geben andreas
künast berichtet die einladung kam
kurzfristig der grund spektakulär
am nachmittag hat das auswärtige amt
alle botschafter der eu-staaten zusammen
getrommelt der politische direktor gibt
bekannt deutschland weist zwei
mitarbeiter der russischen botschaft aus
strafe dafür dass die russischen
behörden
trotz wiederholter hochrangiger und
nachdrücklicher aufforderungen nicht
hinreichend bei der aufklärung des
mordes mitgewirkt haben
ein mord reißt die deutsch-russischen
beziehungen in eine unerwartet heftige
krise das opfer ein staatsfeind seit dem
tschetschenienkrieg der mutmaßliche
täter ein russe er schweigt weil hinter
ihm staatliche stellen stehen sollen hat
heute mittag der generalbundesanwalt die
ermittlungen an sich gezogen
etwas über die bedeutung dieses
verbrechens auch aus dem politischen
hintergrund angeht auf einen politischen
hintergrund soll der verdächtige pass
des mutmaßlichen mörders deuten sein
visum antrag und die art seiner
gefälschten identität erst mal haben die
diese maßnahme ergriffen wissen sie ja
auch durch unsere verlautbarung weil wir
nicht gesehen haben dass russlands und
bei der aufklärung des mordes
unterstützt aus moskau scharfer protest
des außenministeriums unfreundlich und
grundlos sei der berliner verdacht
russland werde nun auch deutsche
diplomaten ausweisen wir sind gezwungen
vergeltungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
den zwei mitarbeitern der russischen
botschaft unter stellt deutschland einen
nachrichtendienstlichen hintergrund sie
haben das land binnen weniger tage zu
verlassen
bringen wir unsere komponenten mit dazu
und gehen zuerst nach moskau weltlicher
guten abend deutschland wir haben gerade
gehört beschwert sich dass russland den
deutschen ermittlern nicht geholfen habe
wäre sowas in einem normalen
kriminalfall anders gewesen
ja durchaus russland ist mitglied der
polizeiorganisation interpol und von
daher schon verpflichtet bei der
aufklärung von kapitalverbrechen
mitzuwirken auch wenn sie außerhalb des
eigenen territoriums stattgefunden haben
so gab es etwa 2015 bei einem mordfall
in herne ein gemeinsames deutsch
russisches vermittlungs
ermittlungsverfahren und seit 20 jahren
schon gibt es eine arbeitsgruppe zur
bekämpfung der organisierten
kriminalität die tagte zuletzt im april
hier in moskau russland kooperiert also
durchaus
allerdings in diesem falle sind ja weder
die fingerabdrücke die aus deutschland
übermittelt worden die des vermutlichen
täters einfach nur analysiert worden
und das lässt mindestens mal den
verdacht aufkommen ob ihr nicht doch die
hohe politik ihre schützende hand über
den täter hält moskau ist über diesen
vorwurf mehr als empört und wir haben es
eben gehört das ganze wird nicht ohne
antwort bleiben und dann gehen wir
weiter nach berlin zu theo koll wie
sieht denn jetzt die linie der
bundesregierung aus ist das ganz klare
haltung oder doch eher vorsichtig
gegenüber moskau
ich würde sagen es ist der typisch
deutsche fall eine art weichen linie
dass der generalbundesanwalt den fall an
sich gezogen hat zeigt ja dass
ausreichend indizien für
staatsterrorismus vorliegen und im
grunde hätte die reaktion schon viel
früher kommen können oder müssen in
jedem fall ist sie überfällig berlin hat
sicher auch deshalb so lange gezögert
weil es sich ja mehr als andere in
europa als politische brücke nach moskau
versteht auch wenn man ehrlich sein soll
diese brücke ist seit langem völlig
vereist und die die rücksichtnahme der
kanzlerin mittlerweile auch überschaubar
gleichzeitig versuchen ja beide seiten
den ukraine gipfel am montag davon nicht
beeinflussen zu lassen denn es gibt
erstmals seit jahren die hoffnung auf
bewegung in diesem festgefahrenen
konflikt das ganze zeigt für politik mit
putin braucht man hier mindestens zwei
gesichter hat sich dank für diese
hintergründe nach berlin und nach moskau
ein mysteriöser mord und die folgen
einen überblick gibt es online auf heute
de oder in der heute app können sie sich
unter anderem durch eine fakten box
klicken mit allem was bekannt ist über
die tat und den verdächtigen
unser nächstes thema da lagen die nerven
blank im vorfeld des nato
jubiläumsgipfels in london so viele
probleme und selbst ein eklat nicht
ausgeschlossen
heute ist der gipfel zu ende gegangen
und das vor diesem hintergrund fast
schon überraschend mit einer gemeinsamen
abschlusserklärung
darin bekräftigen die nato-mitglieder
den kern des bündnisses jeder kommt dem
anderen zur hilfe wenn der angegriffen
wird
außerdem positioniert sich das bündnis
erstmals zu china
man sehe das land als herausforderung an
und als chance und der generalsekretär
soll einen vorschlag machen zur reform
der nato stefan leifert hat die details
wer einen ort wie diesen auf sucht der
hat was zu besprechen
weit vor den toren londons geht die nato
in klausur und mit sich ins gericht das
militärbündnis ist nicht im reinen mit
sich makros rundumschlag hat das
bewiesen ob er seine harschen worte
schon bereue überhaupt nicht nein ich
stehe da ist absolut
außerdem haben meine worte eine debatte
angestoßen die unausweichlich ist 70
wir haben so viele themen zu erklären
zum beispiel die china frage zum ersten
mal in der nato geschichte ring das
bündnis um eine haltung zu neuen
großmacht in fernost ledige reale
stimmen darin überein dass wir uns als
allianz diesem thema stellen müssen und
dass wir einen weg brauchen china davon
zu überzeugen sich in die
rüstungskontrolle einbinden zu lassen
zu den überraschungen dieses gipfels
gehört dass aus dem chefkritiker ein
nato fan geworden ist donald trumps
rollenwechsel lässt viele erstaunen
ich war jetzt auf drei nato gipfeln dies
hier war der beste und sehr besonders
hier herrscht ein guter geist viele
geben jetzt richtig viel geld
wir haben heute wie ich fand eine sehr
konstruktive diskussion gehabt die darin
mündet dass es ein mandat gibt für den
generalsekretär der nato
jens stoltenberg eine reflexionsgruppe
einzurichten die sich mit den
zukunftsfragen der nato beschäftigt
heißt auch der streit ist nur verpackt
die nato zelebriert 70 jahre
vergangenheit und sucht zugleich nach
ihrer zukunft
kurz noch strich drunter mit einem der
den nato gipfel für uns mitverfolgt hat
elmar aufatmen bei der nato aber sind
die probleme jetzt gelöst
nein das sind sie natürlich nicht sie
sind verschoben in die so genannt
reflexionsgruppe die makro unbedingt
wollte und jetzt ein bis zwei jahre
vielleicht zeit hat um eine richtige
strategie zu entwickeln
aber dabei wissen eigentlich alle
regierungen hier dass die probleme nicht
warten dass russland mit seinen
provokationen nicht aufhören wird dass
china weiter einfluss auch innerhalb von
nato mitgliedsstaaten sucht und das
russland und china weiter aufrüsten
weshalb abrüstungsgespräche eigentlich
dringend notwendig wären zum beispiel im
bereich von mittelstreckenraketen also
fazit nach diesem gipfel man will weiter
zusammen bleiben weil man muss aber mit
welchen zielen und mit welchen konzepten
das bleibt offen
matti wissen vielen dank hacker-attacken
datenklau industriespionage die schäden
gehen allein in deutschland jährlich
wohl weit in die milliarden
eine kampfansage gegen gefahr aus dem
netz kommt aus darmstadt heute dort
eröffnete heute athene das nationale
forschungszentrum für cybersicherheit
mehr als 500 wissenschaftler arbeiten
dort künftig daran wie sich
sicherheitslücken schließen lassen
das institut ist nach eigenen angaben
das größte seiner art in europa gucken
wir jetzt auf die spd die steht ja vor
einem spannenden parteitag mit saskia
esken und norbert walter borjans hat die
hpa basis 2 an die spitze gewählt die
die spd verändern wollen aber das
sofortige ende der groko will offenbar
doch keiner riskieren
im aktuellen leitantrag für den
parteitag werden dem koalitionspartner
nämlich keine bedingungen gestellt da
heißt es die spd will mit der union
sprechen den parteilinken reicht das
nicht britta spiekermann am vergangenen
samstag noch die daumen hoch das neue
partei führungsduo hatte versprochen
weiter nach links zu rücken
besonders die saskia esken war der
ausstieg aus der großen koalition eine
ernst zu nehmende option und jetzt
aufbruch in die neue zeit ist der
ehrgeizige titel des vorläufigen spd
leitantrags doch dann folgt man einen
lobgesang auf die arbeit der großen
koalition von nachverhandlungen ist
nicht mehr die rede
man wolle aber mit der union sprechen
und noch etwas überrascht der ausstieg
aus der großen offenbar vom tisch
weder der verbleib in einer koalition
noch der austritt aus ihr sind ein
selbstzweck entscheidend ist ob wir
jetzt mit cdu und csu die weichen
richtig stellen können oder eben nicht
die revolution ist erst einmal
abgeblasen die spd spiel erneut mit
ihrer glaubwürdigkeit kommentiert der
linke flügel der partei ist sehr wichtig
ist dass man hier nicht den eindruck
macht dass man mit scharfer kritik an
der groko ins amt kommt und kaum ist man
im amt dann aus erinnert man sich an
diese kritik nicht mehr die groko
anhänger in der spd hingegen sind
zufrieden
jetzt geht es um mindestlohn jetzt geht
es um klima und ich glaube dass das
wichtige punkte sind und dann wird man
sehen wie wir mit der union klar kommt
tatsächlich ist von einem großen
investitionsprogramm die rede und auch
von mehr ehrgeiz beim klimaschutz aber
wenig konkretes keine fristen keine
androhung von konsequenzen
auch er spielte heute eine interessante
rolle der chef der jusos irritierte mit
der aussage für eine koalition verlasse
gebe einen teil der kontrolle aus der
hand das verstanden manche als warnung
vor dem broker aus stieg kühnert muss
sich wer twitter rechtfertigen
ich maße mir überhaupt nicht an
integrierten natürliche empfehlungen zu
geben oder gar sie zu warnen und ich
habe auch keine angst mit der spd in den
drei monaten wenn es sein muss in einem
bundestagswahlkampf zu ziehen am freitag
beginnt hier der spd-parteitag gut
möglich dass dann viele delegierte ihrem
unmut luft machen das neue führungsduo
steht schon jetzt unter druck
wohnungen sind vor allem in großstädten
heißt begehrt die baufirmen kommen aber
kaum noch hinterher die aufträge
abzuarbeiten
das statistische bundesamt spricht von
einem zunehmenden bau stau und hat neue
zahlen vorgelegt warteten 2008 noch rund
320.000 genehmigte wohnungen auf ihre
fertigstellung waren es im vergangenen
jahr 693.000 also mehr als doppelt so
viel
der grund den bauunternehmen fehlt
personal deutschland gehört der letztes
jahr erstmals zu den staaten die am
stärksten von extremen wetterlagen
betroffen waren
das zeigt der aktuelle klima risiko
index der umweltorganisation germanwatch
darin landet deutschland auf platz drei
nach japan und den philippinen noch vor
madagaskar und indie
im hitze und dürre sommer 2008 zehn
wurden bei uns mehr als 1200 zusätzliche
todesfälle gezählt und die kosten der
schäden rund 4,5 milliarden euro
vom weltklimagipfel immer tritt jetzt
marco deutschland im hitze sommer 2008
zehn monate lang scheint die sonne die
temperaturen 2,9 grad über durchschnitt
und kaum regen menschen sterben getreide
und gemüse verdorrt auf dem feld im
klima risiko index ist deutschland
erstmals auf platz 3 erster wird japan
ebenfalls eines der reichen länder in
diesem jahren wie die besonderheit dass
wir in den top drei des indexes in von
2018 zwei industrieländer haben die
besonders stark betroffen worden sind
das ist das erste mal so in der
geschichte des indexes den wir seit 15
jahren machen wir sehen daran dass alle
länder alle regionen der welt betroffen
sind
der in madrid vorgestellte index zeigt
die schäden und todesfälle durch extreme
wetterereignisse
die sind zwar nicht immer eindeutig der
erderwärmung zuzuordnen forscher lassen
aber keinen zweifel
sie spielt eine immer größere rolle am
ende es ist so dass wir durch den
klimawandel mehr energie in
klimasystemen haben und diese energie
wird umgesetzt und das kann eben durch
sind bewegungen sein das kann eben auch
durch stärkere verdunstung sein
das kann dazu führen dass an bestimmten
gebieten wir trockenheiten haben aber
eben auch dass eben die atmosphäre mehr
wasser aufnehmen weil sie wärmer ist und
dass eben auch wieder zu stärkeren
niederschlägen in anderen orten führt
der langzeittrend ist dabei klar vor
allem arme länder werden getroffen dort
gab es die meisten der fast 500 1000
toten die seit 1999 gezählt wurden hilfe
für die opfer des klimawandels auch das
ein großes thema bei den verhandlungen
in madrid
und damit sind wir beim sport christin
bin schon genauer gesagt wintersport
biathlon weltcup in östersund schweden
auch das zweite saisonrennen ohne
podestplatz für die deutschen starter
der lange einzelwettbewerb der herren
über 20 kilometer endete mit einem
überragenden vierfach erfolg für die
franzosen
bester dieses quartetts der siebenmalige
weltcup-gesamtsieger martha folk art er
ist wieder da knapp ein jahr liegt sein
letzter sieg zurück heute nun die
erlösung
es war eine schwierige saison zum glück
konnte ich meine zweifel beiseite
schieben ich bin sehr stolz dass ich
wieder auf meinem alten leistungsniveau
nur beim letzten schießen leistet sich
der 31-jährige einen fehler den kann er
verschmerzen denn er hat genügend
vorsprung auf seinen mannschaftskollegen
seymour die tür der ebenfalls 19 mal
trifft ein französischer abend also hier
in östersund bei diesem einzelrennen der
siegermacht rocard zweiter von links
eingerahmt von seinen
mannschaftskollegen der deutsche am
tiefer stürzte und zog sich eine
platzwunde am kopf zu
deutschlands handballerinnen sind ja
bereits für die hauptrunde der
weltmeisterschaft in japan qualifiziert
nach drei siegen nacheinander mussten
sie aber nun gegen die
titelverteidigerin ebenfalls aus
frankreich einen ersten dämpfer
hinnehmen
die enttäuschung ist ihnen anzusehen
die deutschen nationalspielerinnen gegen
frankreich immer im hintertreffen
der weltmeister durchweg schneller und
effizienter deutschland dennoch mit
starker leistung auch nach einem
fünf-tore-rückstand mitte der zweiten
halbzeit kämpfte sich die mannschaft
wieder heran schaffte aber nicht den
ausgleich
der knappe sieg gegen dänemark steckt
noch zu sehr in den knochen
man hat einfach gemerkt es war gestern
in extremen hartes spiel hatten
und haben hat heute einige chancen
liegen lassen am ende verliert
deutschland gegen die weltmeisterinnen
mit 25 27
mit wie vielen punkten das team in die
hauptrunde geht hängt vom abschließenden
gruppenspiel am freitag gegen südkorea
und dem ergebnis zwischen frankreich und
dänemark ab christin eine riesen ehrung
für einen ganz großen basketball legende
dirk nowitzki bekommt vom
bundespräsidenten das
bundesverdienstkreuz und zwar nicht für
seine ihre karriere auf dem court
sondern als unicef-botschafter und für
seine zwei stiftungen mit denen
unterstützte seit jahren vor allem
benachteiligte kinder übrigens frank
walter steinmeier ist ein meter 78 groß
die lottozahlen lauten 12 13 35 45 46 48
und die superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
dem zdf text auf seite 55 7 so fast
überall in deutschland gibt es morgen
viel sonnenschein das sind doch mal gute
aussichten gleich von präsident ali
heute journal 22 uhr mit dem kollegen
claus kleber und morgen sind wir wieder
für sie da und zwar sehr gerne bis dann
in allen ein angenehmer
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unsere karte von
heute mittag zeigt viel grün das
bedeutete es gab viel sonnenschein das
haben sie wahrscheinlich auch selber
gemerkt aber in einigen ecken
deutschlands war es ziemlich dicht
bewölkt bzw neblig trüb im südwesten zum
beispiel temperaturen nur bei minus zwei
grad unter dem dichten nebel und so geht
es morgen auch weiter schauen wir in die
nacht und verbreiten sich die nebel
banker aus in der mitte klart es auf und
es wird frostig kalt fast überall an den
alpen temperaturen bis minus acht grad
kalt bis zur elbe hoch ist es frostig
nur ganz im norden sind es sechs grad
morgen starten wir zunächst mit nebel in
den tag und da kann sich durchaus auch
länger halten
später zeigt sich aber häufiger die
sonne im nordwesten da kommen neue
wolken auf die temperaturen dazu in den
nebelgebieten bei werten zwischen 0 und
2 grad ganz im norden sind sechs card
und an den alpen bei viel sonne scheint
bei acht grad
die nächsten tage am freitag ist es im
süden noch trockener war im nord westen
kommt regen auf und viel wind über der
nordsee dann sturm zwei bis neun grad
und das wochenende
das geht ziemlich windig und nass weiter
damit ein schöner abend